13 12. i was a part of a hell of a
wrestling revival and renaissance
because at a time where there was only
the wwe nxt gave you an alternative
product
i think i feel like you were part of
peak nxt which i think it'll never get
better i mean you had samoa joe finn
balor right charlotte sasha becky alexa
bliss ftr but you know buddy kevin owens
blake and kevin owens and sami zayn and
adrian neville and you know it was wild
yeah it was to me it was it was that
[ __ ] i think at that time it was
better than um and that's what i mean
people got to realize like oh they want
to sit here and point the finger like oh
this guy can't wrestle this guy can't do
this like dog
you're you got eight matches on a card
all right you got your heavyweight title
match you got your what intercontinental
title match you got your tag team title
match you got your women's title match
then you got
a royal rumble hodgepodge with a bunch
of people because if somebody gets hurt
on one of those shows you need to fill
it with somebody right so maybe you got
like a 16 man tag right and that payday
ain't gonna be as good as the main event
guy right the guy who's in the main
event versus the guy who's in the rumble
with 20 30 other people man me and cass
without titles had our own match on the
wwe card whether it was nxt or the wwe
that was crazy to me it was like bro
there's only eight spots
and four of them are for titles
but enzo and cass are so beloved that
they don't need a title for their match
you're still going to go nuts when they
come out it doesn't have to be for
anything and me and cass didn't have to
over complicate it it wasn't like
kickouts and guys you know he was like
no i get i talk [ __ ] i get beat up i
take cash he cleans house everybody's
happy
so i'm gonna ask you this so um
good job
fun factor all the way through the room
it felt like it went from like you
because because
you know where are these energy drinks
coming from who's got one of these
[ __ ] i guess this takes five years
nobody got one just got one from the
liquor store these are good uh no but i
felt like it was crazy just because like
it felt like you guys were like the fan
favorite in nxt
uh i forget which pay-per-view or which
when you guys got called up but i
remember watching it on tv when you guys
like made your uh
i might have been raw or your your big
your big day raw was the the night after
wrestlemania in dallas in 2016. i
remember watching this when we debuted
but we had been held in nxt a lot longer
than everyone else yeah because i think
everybody was like what the [ __ ]
whenever enzo and cass coming up man
hunter wasn't about to give us up dog
yeah [ __ ] enzo in cash was his
drug
he wasn't about to send us up to [ __ ] he
said hey brother we're just starting to
fill these houses out you ain't taking
enzo cass finn balor adrian neville sami
zayn sasha charlotte and becky all at
[ __ ] once at least
and we became the victim of that [ __ ]
keeping us down in nxt waiting but the
timing is everything it couldn't work
out better the crowd was hungry by the
time we debuted nxt was such a hot show
people knew who we were
what was it about uh what you were doing
that uh caught john cena's attention you
think
dog the first day that i debuted in nxt
i had just gotten my name i didn't even
i hadn't even gotten a name i hadn't had
any matches i had made a youtube video
that went viral got signed by the wwe
had never had a wrestling match in my
life but had killed it every week in
promo class since the day i showed up
and now dusty rhodes is all about it and
the other coaches want to get me [ __ ]
canned and fired the head coach at the
time was really rough on me and i didn't
understand i didn't understand wrestling
i didn't understand like
getting the heat right [ __ ] his heat
like what you're a man you're gonna go
talk about me behind my [ __ ] back
that backstage [ __ ] like i'm a
[ __ ] dude like i come from jersey
yeah if you talk [ __ ] in my neighborhood
about another dude we're going to call
him on the phone and tell you tell him
right now or go to his face right you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just weird oh [ __ ]
it's this weird wrestling culture right
a few times i'm in a [ __ ] car with a
few guys hearing them talk [ __ ] about
other people i spoke up was kind of like
hey bro why don't you go [ __ ] say
that [ __ ] to him and they quickly kind
of realized like oh enzo ain't with the
shits
and i kind of i think i got ixnayed from
the weird sex world
and and the secret world and the burial
talking [ __ ] world there was a weird
section i'm sure there's a sex company
going on in backstage all right and i
know i've heard things
but bro we've seen videos dude i've
never got tied into any of that [ __ ]
because i was i feel like the outsider
of pro wrestling that came in but then i
got lucky because the likes of finn
balor who were in new japan at the time
are watching nxt and they're popping for
enzo and cats right but they're just
asking people who they know who are in
wrestling like yo what's what's that
doing cast like like how where did they
come from were they wrestlers and
everybody's like no enzo and casa they
never wrestled before really cass had a
few matches right and went to wrestling
school with johnny rods in brooklyn so
he definitely was trying to do it but
this [ __ ] just kind of fell in my lap
wow and i just kind of walked in
unknowingly just being me and that [ __ ]
worked for me but i can't give that
advice to other people i wouldn't i
would not not everybody has uh your your
talent on the mic brother i'll [ __ ]
sell a ketchup popsicle to a [ __ ] of
white gloves you know what i'm saying
i'm [ __ ] out here dog like [ __ ]
well pushing the sail forward always
closing look under your [ __ ] seats
right now all right you know what i mean
i'm [ __ ] in here give me the
microphone